[Music]
all right let's go to ann in salt lake
city what's up anne
hey living the dream how are you john me
too me too
are you a youtuber also because man it
is awesome over here
you're like no i've got a real job
hey so what's up how can i help
hey um so my husband has been binging
and purging to lose weight
how do i talk to him about how dangerous
this is to his health even though all
he's seeing is the result
and losing weight
yeah it's hard because it works right
yeah
so how long has been going on
um he started as kind of a coping
mechanism um a couple years ago and we
are kind of going through some marriage
um issues
and
i didn't realize that he had went back
to it once he was getting serious about
losing weight
so i would say for the weight it's been
about
i would say four to six months
is it daily weekly how often
um
i would say
bi-weekly um that you know
right yeah that i know when he like
feels like he fell off the wagon and you
know he's eaten too much that week or
whatever or like i'll bring home pizza
because i want to surprise him he'll
then he'll just yeah go
do that and it's
yeah
so
my oh man
i have some questions to ask you but i
want to be really careful about how i
ask them one is i don't want to set a
precedent for i'm
for other people listening to the show
that these are always appropriate
questions in every situation
um yeah and
i don't want you to hear them ashaming
questions okay is that fair yeah
yeah
absolutely
you brought it up so
if if you have a husband who's
struggling with disordered eating
and he's really working towards a goal
how would a surprise of pizza
be helpful or loving for him
it's not it sounds like a thing it's
that's a surprise for you because i love
pizza i love bringing it home
it doesn't sound like that is y'all two
on the same page for let's do something
together for both of us
is it fair
yeah absolutely
uh
did he wrestle with disorder eating
years before
or body dysmorphia is he struggling with
his self-image or is it just something
that
he took on when you're did you almost
lose your marriage
yes was your infidelity involved
no no what happened
um
we're pretty young
and we've only been married five years
this year um and so
just a lot of growing up to do yeah
there you go we all did it yeah that's
right that's right yeah it's yeah so and
just uh some trust issues and
okay
yeah um so
here's the way forward i think
um i think twofold number one
the conversation is not you need to stop
doing x y and z
all right when that happens
immediately it's fight or flight he's
under attack
and
the ability to hear you is off the
ability to process logically what you're
saying is off the ability to respond
clearly is off okay
it's all about survival and sometimes
survival is
destructive behaviors all the time
survival is a flow of cortisol and
adrenaline that just melts our bodies
from inside out when it's pervasive okay
my guess is he's been doing that for a
long long time
so the conversation is less about hey
you got to stop doing this
and more
here's what i need
here's what i and need
i need the man that i love
to stop killing himself
which is what he's doing
i need um this so so we're not judging
his character right he's clearly hurting
and he's sick and he's covering up and i
don't think this makes him a bad guy or
weak or a coward i think he's really
hurting sounds like he's sick
is that fair
yep
have you felt him to be weak and a
coward and just quit doing this is
disgusting
no
what are you feeling towards him
um i'm feeling
i
i'm feeling scared for him and
kind of disappointed
in a way
because i know some of it is emotional
and i don't a huge
yeah i
i can't like help him or be there for
him
in the way he needs i can't lose the
weight for him and i can't
you know like
yeah that's right so in there's a
powerlessness to that that you have to
feel if you try to avoid that
powerlessness that that avoidance comes
out in rage and anger and yelling and
you mean looks okay
so own that powerlessness
and then divert that energy after you've
owned it for a season and it seems like
a day or a couple of days right it's not
like a year um and
look unless it may be a year look at him
and
no the only thing i can control is anne
and so what he needs right now is
somebody who loves him probably three or
four or five people who love him
who will circle up and say hey
here's here's just the data we love you
and as people who love you we
need you
to love yourself as much as we do we
need you to stop killing yourself
and if you're willing to
get well i'm willing to walk through
hell with you arm and arm
and i'll go with you
um
i'm prepared to do that because i love
you that's the conversation forward not
what'd you eat today did you have any
did you put sauce on it that's the you
know what i mean
and especially not bringing pizza home
to celebrate
um where does he get where does he get
in mind and that's not the only thing
you bring home by the way is it no no
um
a lot of times when one person in in a
couple loses weight
the other person resents them because
they have to change their life my wife
for a season was really frustrated that
she couldn't just keep a bag of cookies
in the house it was annoying for her
because she's not the problem i was
and um
until she made peace with it and then
she hides stuff from me too by the way i
find that every once in a while
that's not super healthy but
she ultimately made peace i love him
more than this than a if i need a cookie
i'll go get one and by the way i don't
need those you know what i mean
yeah a lot of times when somebody's
losing weight trying to go on this
journey they feel the disdain of their
partner
and it just spins that shame cycle up
more that not only am i and i'm saying
things imaginary things
not only am i disgusting not only am i
unhealthy
not only am i not attractive
now i'm also
like taking away my wife's ability just
to enjoy dinner the dinner that she
wants to have
and that cycle of shame sends somebody
sh
you see what i'm saying sends them
straight to destructive behaviors yep
would you be willing to go all in with
him
oh absolutely where does he where does
he
did he learn the idea that he needs to
lose weight
um just from looking at pictures of
himself and he just doesn't feel
he wants to get back to the way he was
in high school and
um
yeah and we have been working out
together and trying to eat better
together and
um yeah so what i'll tell you is
i've been in this in this game for 20
something years
and i'm just now signing up for yet
another coach i can't do it by myself
and the
uh he was on the show my buddy elaine
norton who's won the he's like set
national records for weight lifting and
he's the protein guru he's entering the
nationals again and um in fact by the
time this comes out nationals probably
over and he got a coach
and so i would tell you if y'all are
being serious about it it's time to get
some professional help and stop just
looking at youtube clips
and also your husband's got to go see
somebody and i think that starts with a
couple of y'all who people who love him
surrounding him and saying hey
we love you enough to tell you that
we're watching you kill yourself and
we don't want to watch that anymore we
love you too much
and it's really important for you i
would spend some time writing down what
do you need
how can he help meet your needs and vice
versa how can you help meet his needs i
think it'd be really important for you
to sit down and say i have not helped
and i'm sorry i'm not going to bring ice
cream and cookies and pizza home anymore
let's get with a coach and get an actual
diet plan that's going to work for us
not a diet plan but it's just a
structured eating a healthy eating plan
moving forward i think diets are stupid
let's get a a
a plan moving forward that we're both
going to be on the same page and there
is going to be days we're frustrated
there's going to be days where annoyed
and we're going to keep plugging along
keep plugging along and he's gonna have
to deal with the mental health aspect of
his disordered eating okay
um all of that starts with connection
all of that starts with love all of that
starts with a group of people saying i'm
on your team and that starts with you
look at him in the eye and saying i'm
ready to go to hell back if you are
because i'm in